Speaker 1: If you were worried that since leaving
office, Donald Trump was short on grifting donor
money. I want to put to ease, put to rest those
concerns. Donald Trump has put nearly $1,000,000
of donor money into his own pockets since leaving
office. Since leaving office. This is based on a
Huffington Post analysis of a new FEC filing.
Donald Trump failed to spend much of the money
he raised over the last two years to win Georgia
Senate seats or fund the red wave in 2022. But he
did manage, writes S.V. Date Hey for HuffPost.
He did manage to put nearly $1,000,000 of his
donors contributions right back into his own cash
registers from the day he left office through the
end of 2022. The coup, attempting former
presidents. Various political committees,
spent $905,000 at his properties. According
to that HuffPost Analysis. You don't need to
even really look at the details, but when you
do, you find $100,000 in hotel spending here,
$400,000 in in hotel spending, their Trump Tower
rent offices, all of these different things. Now,
the reality is that even this number of $1,000,000
doesn't fully represent the degree to which Donald
Trump is funneling donor money back into his own
pockets. There's actually a lot of different ways
that this is done. One way, of course, is by
raising donor money and then having campaign
or PAC spending be spent at your own businesses.
Another way is to pay off your own campaign debts,
even when you claim to be raising money for
something different. There are so many different
ways that you can funnel money that is being
donated for political reasons. Back it back into
your own pockets. You can also use your personal
properties and have foreign dignitaries who visit
you, as so many did, and stayed at Trump's D.C.
hotel in order to ingratiate themselves with
you by staying at your hotel, which of course,
makes you money while you are president of the
United States. There's all of these different
ways that you can do it. What we know is that
it is a grift and a scam all the way down. And
if Republican voters want him to, he's going to
do it again in 2024. We will stay on the finance
story because it's really as big a story as any
of the other stuff. The finance grift scam that
Trump has now run for six years is extraordinary,
and he's getting away with it, at least for now.
All of the clips I played here will be on our
YouTube channel. Find it at YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show. Make sure you're subscribed.